i
a
si bill están ya más y rusia no sabe
cómo apagarlas en nuestros regiones se
han tenido que declarar el estado de
emergencia y la superficie total asolada
supera ya el millón de hectáreas los
ecologistas y el gobierno culpan a ambos
al cambio climático los incendios
ocurren en zonas remotas donde el agua
no puede servir de cortafuegos porque la
sequía hace que el fuego avance durante
semanas en lo que llevamos de año se han
perdido 9 millones de hectáreas lo que
equivale a toda la extensión de portugal
y queda lo más difícil porque en la
época de mayor riesgo para los bosques
se produce precisamente entre finales de
julio y principios de agosto además el
problema es que el hollín y las cenizas
que generan los incendios aceleran el
deshielo del ártico y la capa de hielo
permafrost también se ve afectada
liberando gases a la atmósfera que
contribuyen al calentamiento global
[Música]
las muy graves inundaciones en el
occidente de alemania los últimos días
pero también en otras partes de europa
han vuelto a poner el enfoque político
en la necesidad urgente de aumentar los
esfuerzos en la lucha contra el cambio
climático esto es algo que aquí en
alemania han enfatizado los políticos
una y otra vez desde que comenzó la
crisis lo han enfatizado por un lado a
la luz de los eventos actuales pues se
ha explicado que el aumento de las
temperaturas hace que los fenómenos
meteorológicos extremos como los que se
vivieron aquí en alemania sean
particularmente intensos pero lo han
enfatizado también por otro lado de cara
al futuro pues los expertos han
explicado que lejos de ser situaciones
únicas emergencias como las de el
occidente de alemania y otros países
europeos podrían volverse cada vez más
frecuentes
[Música]
el retorno a la normalidad después de la
pandemia y la recuperación económica
podrían llevar a un récord emisiones de
gases invernaderos para el 2023 así lo
asegura la agencia internacional de
energía argumentando que el dinero que
se va a invertir en energía verde no
será suficiente para hacerle contrapeso
a las altas temperaturas en eeuu por
ejemplo estas altas temperaturas han
contribuido a propagar los incendios en
la costa oeste y el humo de estos
incendios ha llegado a ciudades como
nueva york en washington en la costa
este afectando considerablemente la
calidad del aire pero según autoridades
el incendio the bootleg en oregón
precisamente es apenas una muestra de lo
que será la larga temporada de incendios
en eeuu impulsadas por las altas
temperaturas que en el estado de montana
por ejemplo han llegado a 44 grados
centígrados muy por encima de
promovió
[Música]